by the way I guess Tan mom is having
another pay-per-view special like you
know on computer dude now JD told me he
refuses to cover it unless he force him
for watch it might force him
you really are refusing to watch it
they're just not that entertaining and
I'm what here but you talked about how
about tanning oh it's a special on
tanning it's our most requested topic
JD mom she must be getting better at
this JD how does she haven't deserves
gotten better
I really wish JD you would watch it
because it's going to be really good
this time we're doing a half hour just
on SPF [ __ ]
can eat your face and I'm like I'm
making him watch this he's got it what
if he only has an hour left to live you
know Sam I'm do you remember a time
where you swear the light bulb went on
over your head and you went you know
what my thing is
tanning I love to be in the Sun the
beach and just as I got older I realized
that you know you can make a lot of
money and being this but I didn't want
it to happen the way it did with um you
know with my daughter the way you know
they blame me for the whole thing which
I won but I'm just saying like then you
know people would realize you know how
smart that I am and that it's not just a
my never noticed I asked you a question
when did you realize you wanted to tan
and now we're up to your daughter and
how smart you are
this car has no brakes once we start we
don't stop okay my puppet I'm trying
just ask you when did you start to enjoy
tanning during Vietnam I was a baby
I've ever watching the news and I
remember thinking this is terrible
I grew up and the Space Shuttle blew up
the Challenger
then I was like I didn't want things to
go that way the question was when did
you start enjoying panic no comment
I don't want to talk about something
about you knew that you could make a lot
of money I would promote things outside
of handy salon and I'll be standing out
there and you know everyone's hot
walking out I was rolling in the money
for the ice cream and so I mean you look
confused
chapter four by the wait am i puppet you
look very beautiful I'm watching you I
can't wait to put this up on the app you
for protecting your lips you know you
have a nice yes it's a special coating
that Turtle Wax
good luck with your special I guess I
don't know how you order that but I'm
sure you everyone will figure it out in
the audience I'm sure they're gonna want
to be right there with you I have no
idea what she's saying to purchase your
tickets go to
you